Is it okay for me to use the inference on while I'm on a cortical steroid for poison ivy.
I, I would say no for a couple of reasons.
You know, steroids are going to be antithlamatory.
A soda is inclampatory.
You know, that's what you're trying to do is to create a fever state.
Um, and you're kind of going against it.
Plus you'll number two, you will detox the steroids through the skin much quicker and you'll get less benefit from them.
Number three, you could actually spread the poison ivy around because you're going to be sweating more.
So I would stay away from the soda personally while you're on the steroids.
For the reason that you detox the cortical steroids quicker.
You're going to decrease the, you're going to increase in inflammatory response.
You're going to be fighting against the cortical steroids.
And the simple fact that you have poison ivy that you can, it could spread more.